make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're officially getting into
powers of X really it's like powers of
ten I think is what it is implements I
think it's house of X and then powers of
ten I think it's how this comes out
anyway powers of X basically is what
it's called or at least that's what I'm
calling it and this this is mm-hmm marry
some do this story is really really good
at least this first issue is amazing
alright so in traditional hitman fashion
what we get is basically this kind of
time chronology that we're gonna follow
over the course of this series right if
you know how to read Hickman's stories
like if you know how to interpret what
he does in the beginning then you know
how to basically navigate the waters of
the story going forward right so we get
basically year 1 which is the current
year right now or the the I guess really
in the past right like you know the idea
of when the x-men were first founded
essentially which is the dream of
Charles Xavier following that you go
into year 10 which could basically
conceive or be assumed to be the present
day which is the world as it exists now
and then year 100 which is a hundred
years from now the war that breaks out
and we'll talk about that here in a
second and then following that is when
mutants basically ascend to their higher
state of evolution so it's really really
cool it's really really badass but what
this does is it initially picks up with
Charles Xavier is kind of meandering
around and just sort of looking at
things and then ultimately he's met by
what appears to be more a McTaggart now
more of a tagger in Marvel Comics so
those are guys who renew and I feel like
this is really kind of an important
thing to explain here those are guys who
are new to the x-men more McTaggart is
not new she's been around for a long
long long time but the basis behind her
is that if Charles Xavier is the
instructor for mutants which is to say
the one who teaches them how to use
their powers then Warmack Hagrid is a
mutant geneticist who understands how
their powers work now the two of them
often work hand in hand and the way this
played out is that she had her own group
for example like the new mutants a lot
of you guys have probably heard of that
if only because the movie's supposed to
be coming out which I'm probably not
gonna go see the idea behind that is it
was a handful of mutants that have been
discovered by by more McTaggart that she
was keeping on your island to understand
their powers how they work how they
function to see if they're kind of like
any significant danger now there were
the two of them working hand in hand
what would happen here is that if if
Charles Xavier discovered a mutants who
had really any any powers they could be
classified as dangerous right like
anything that was unpredictable or could
cause all kinds of problems and he
didn't really know how they worked he
would take them to more McTaggart and
more McTaggart would analyze their
powers and then give Charles Xavier an
answer and then Charles Xavier would
cater his teaching process
around the nature of their powers right
so uh it's kind of cool in terms of how
they function but the discussion here is
Charles Xavier kind of hitting at the
idea at a more in McTaggart that like he
wants to create a better world now of
course he doesn't reveal to her here
that he has telepathy Charles Xavier
kept his powers guarded for a long long
time right it was one of the big things
about his character the first time that
anybody really learned about his
abilities outside of his brother Cain
Marko who eventually became the
juggernaut was Magneto when the two of
them got into a bar fight with a whole
bunch of different guys and they both
use their powers and they basically kind
of revealed themselves to the other in
terms of what they could do what their
abilities were and then I kind of led to
a rift later on when they had two
different ideologies on how to navigate
the waters between mutant and human
relations but the idea behind this is
it's really a you know more McTaggart
saying hey I went to go see a
fortune-teller and this fortune-teller
came to me with a vision of source you
came to me with the magician the tower
and the devil himself and it's kind of
cool to see these these things play out
because we'll actually find out who
these characters are so I'm not gonna
spoil anything right now what she tells
Charles Xavier here where he says well
you know and I had this dream of a
better world I want to create a better
place and things like that and what more
my tiger says is it's not really a dream
if it's real and so what this does is
really seem to hit at the idea that the
basis behind why Charles Xavier pursue
up her pursued his dream of a peaceful
coexistence is because the fact that
like more McTaggart would have inspired
him to do that but then this is when we
start to learn that not everything is
what it appears to be now again we're
ballparking here when it comes to more
weren't explicitly told as her but has
kind of left to assume that it is but
then she addresses him directly as
Charles and the fact that he doesn't
know who she is the fact that he's never
met her really kind of begs the question
how does she know who he is and he and
she says when we go back quite a ways
read my mind and see I suppose it's kind
of like okay so like it's it's it's
business it's a mystery like it's
mysterious and that's the nature of
hickman writing right like we probably
won't get an answer to that question and
sure like powers of X number four is
it's crazy the way the whole thing works
out now at this point we basically pick
up with the modern day right the x-men
year 10 what's currently going on right
now and this basically follows the
aftermath of house of X so if you guys
haven't read that story or haven't seen
that video then make sure you go check
it out right I'll have the link down in
the description or you can go and grab
the comic or whatever the case is for
you but basically this follows the
immediate aftermath of that right the Oh
mystique basically showing back up to
krakoa the the current residents the
location that the x-men resided or at
least so that a large large majority of
the mutants
that only the mutants can access she
comes back of course with this with this
hard drive of sorts hands it over to
magneto and then we get our first real
display here of of Charles Xavier now
again it's not really Charles Xavier
putting like the the full totality of
his power he's just kind of there and we
really don't know the intentions of
Xavier all indications and the in the
whole town is being put off here is he
seems like he's kind of a dick now like
he's kind of a bad guy and and maybe
maybe he's not we're not really sure but
when it comes to Xavier it's always been
trying to achieve a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants but when you
have phrases being thrown out there
where Xavier says dear humanity while
you slept the world changed it's just
kind of like okay so it seems like
Xavier is becoming a little more
militaristic or a little more extreme in
terms of pursuing his own goals and
that's kind of the crazy thing here
because as this happens you end up
having this this you know sort of
discussion between himself and mystique
you know where she says we have more
demands because of what it is has taken
place here so obviously mystique isn't
really doing this for the betterment of
the mutant kind and Xavier says well
that's fine you know because we ought we
also have demands to like we have things
that we want to achieve as well and in
this world if you're going to live here
in kokoa and you're gonna be a part of
it then everybody here owes something
everybody here is gonna have to pay a
price and that's kind of the crazy thing
because we don't find out what that is
instead we jump to what I think is
actually the coolest part of the story
the man-machine war and this is awesome
so this place did takes place 100 years
in the future right I mean totally guys
could tell I'm excited about this this
place takes place 100 years into the
future and basically a war is broken out
between humanity and mutants but the
difference here is that the the humanity
has out light itself with machines now
what this appears to be is kind of like
it's almost kind of like the Days of
Future Passed film kind of being rolled
into the comic book form not in the
exact way right it's a lot more extreme
here and really the indication as it was
put off by it is a future pass on the
movie was that humans were working with
the Sentinels but really more because it
was like if you don't were going to
eradicate you right so it was more of an
undesirable alliance between these two
groups and this it really looks like
they're actually working in a peaceful
coexistence with each other and of
course what they're doing you know what
it really seems to have happened here is
that these mutants have basically gotten
their hands on something in particular
now what I also want you to take note of
is one of these characters here that has
a black brain and what kind of follow up
without here in a second and find out
what's going on but of course she's
immediately captured by a combination of
really the forces of like these massive
sentinels and also with these super
advanced artificial artificial
elegent robots now what you also have
here is a young girl who looks like
she's like the daughter of like
Nightcrawler and magic and then somebody
who also kind of looks like a spin-off
version of Nightcrawler right so like
these two people look like they're
descended from Nightcrawler himself and
it's kind of weird in terms of how their
physical depiction comes out here but
the way this is being done is that this
this particular mutant with the black
brain is essentially being taken by
humanity right I mean like you know her
chance of escape is virtually
non-existent but the idea is that what
this young boy here this this red
skinned mutant guy he doesn't really
want to fight he follows very much in
line with Nightcrawler where he's like
I'm really more of a peaceful guy but
this kid is really more like a priest he
really follows a strong religion and
truly believes in the act of pacifism
and so where you end up having you know
this this young girl whose address is
being Rasputin which we'll talk about
that here in a second but when she's
addresses Rasputin and she basically
jumps in destroys one of the machines
and then tries to rescue this woman with
a black brain ultimately it doesn't work
out instead this young girl is taken
away by the Sentinels and in Rasputin is
asserted as kind of left to survive as
best you can and that's when we start to
get into what's going on here and so
what we end up finding out is that
somewhere between the present day and
100 years in the future that the villain
mr. sinister became an ally or at least
seemed to become an ally of the mutant
population now the reason why this is
important is because those guys don't
know mr. sinister is a guy named
Nathaniel Essex right at one point in
time he was a human but he was obsessed
with the idea that the human genealogy
was predicated on change that somewhere
along the line the genes of humans were
modified and they were he was correct
about that but he didn't really have the
evidence to prove it he didn't really
know exactly how it had happened of
course we know it was due to the
Celestials but the result is that he
believed that somewhere along the line
that whatever these genes were would
begin to manifest and people would begin
to develop powers and he simply called
the mutants now eventually the villain
apocalypse approached death annual Essex
after learning about his his discussions
and his topics and research and so on
and Nathaniel Essex basically revealed
to apocalypse that he was a mutant which
was the first time that apocalypse
realized what he was and so following
that apocalypse basically uses
technology to turn Nathaniel Essex into
mr. sinister and give him an insanely
long life if not full on immortality and
so ever since then Nathaniel Essex has
always been toying with the idea of
messing with you or with with mutant
genes and seeing if he could just create
more powerful characters right I mean
mutants have always just kind of an
experiment for him now because of the
story The Adventures of Cyclops in
Phoenix we ended up finding out the
reason why it is a sinister was so
obsessed with creating a child
based on the genes of Cyclops in in Jean
Grey well fine we'll talk about more you
know talk about that more like a
different video or something like that
but at the moment what seems to have
happened here is sometime between this
100 year window the present day and 100
years from now that sinister began the
purpose when this war broke out he began
basically genetically modifying mutants
and so what he would do is he would take
a mutant or or or he would like build a
mutant from scratch and he would give
him the genes of like multiple
characters and so for this character rat
Rasputin she basically has the telepathy
of Clinton choir who's an omega-level
telepath she's got the powers of Mikhail
Rasputin who's the brother of Colossus
and he can basically manipulate energy
the powers of kitty pryde to face
through objects she's got the healing
factor of Laura Kinney she's literally
like a one-stop-shop now the way this
worked is that you basically had like
generations 1 2 3 & 4
and as these generations went on the
likelihood of survival for these
generations began to drop off in the
sense that like there was more of a
chance of destruction here now what the
mutants began to realize over time is
that none of this was really being done
by sinister for the purpose of helping
the incon it was being done by sinister
for his own goals his own nefarious
purposes and so eventually what seems to
have happened here is sinister was
working for the purpose of developing
kind of like this perfect mutant
more-or-less and when that happened he
would hand it over to humanity and for
whatever that reason happened to be
right most likely because humanity had
promised him the ability to experiment
on mutants as much as he wanted to when
they were captured and so on and so
forth blended of happening is that when
sinister defected to the human side he
was publicly executed we don't really
know that the explicit details of this
you know we just kind of know the
project side of what sinister is doing
or at least he was doing and then most
likely we'll find an answer to that
later on down the line but that kind of
begs the question if humans and mutants
are working together then who's running
the show here and that's when we get an
answer to the question that the show is
being ran by two people the first is an
evolved human who basically is going by
the name Omega and the second is Nimrod
and that's the coolest thing because
Nimrod is a character that we have not
seen for a long long time those guys who
don't know
Nimrod hails from Days of Future past
right so the idea was that signals had
taken over North America during Days of
Future past and they basically you know
they they captured all mutants they
could find everywhere and even humans
were thrown into internment camps but
what the signals were working on was a
perfect version of themselves a perfect
a perfect Sentinel but what seems to
have happened here is that Nimrod has
been created yet again the difference is
that this version of Nimrod
does not appear to be like like the one
that
normally used to write like the
traditional version of Nimrod is pretty
screwed out like he's pretty dark and
pretty sadistic we can assume this is
the same version and just kind of
evolved or it's a new version we don't
really have any answers to that question
you know it's kind of left to sort of
make our own guess and just kind of go
from there
but with these humans showing up with
this Blackberry mutant who's now known
as sila belle what we learn is that
they've gone through all kinds of like
torturous systems in order to get the
information out of her in terms of what
Rasputin and these other mutants were
after and where she refused to reveal
this information what Nimrod basically
says is like what they're gonna do is
they're going to take her and they're
going to give her what's called a bath
and the reason why they call it that is
because they're going to essentially put
her in a tank where she's gonna be
broken down not really broken down in
terms a physical form but where nanites
are essentially going to enter and take
over her body and all the information
that she has is going to essentially
become a part of the Nimrod mainframe
and that is to say like the Machine
mainframe and all that information will
be readily available and it's kind of a
crazy scenario because you know sine
labelled initially kind of tries to put
off this error like I'm not afraid I'm
not worried about this and if you think
threatening me is really gonna cause
problems for me you have no idea what
I'm really about but ultimately none of
it matters because when she gets dunked
into this tank then and I just do their
work and she's a shell of her former
self just like that she's essentially
gone it's a death as she can't really
escape from right I mean she's kind of
stuck there for for essentially all time
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
because all the information she has is
going to be extracted all the
information she has is gonna be taken
away but her physical form is not going
to be destroyed she's just gonna kind of
be left there now the indication here is
that in terms of her consciousness and
her sentience it's still there she's
just kind of in a catatonic state but
also kind of seemingly aware of what's
going on I know it seems like a
contradiction but that seems to be the
way these systems work right I mean
she's just kind of taken over and that's
the end of her but one of the things
that needs to be pointed out here is
that silo Belle was actually what's
called a hound now Jonathan Hickman is
not making this up this is actually
something that existed from the events
of Days of Future past and even to a
degree the age of apocalypse so the way
this works when you come out of Days of
Future past and you kind of look at that
scenario and one of the questions a lot
of people had is well why didn't you
Tintin how is it the signals were
finding them and the signals were doing
that by using hounds they were using
mutants to hunt other Newtons and that's
the way this played out here it was the
creation of hounds designed to track
down other mutants now this seems to be
an indication of like what sinister was
doing when he defected from human from
mutant kind and then went over to
humanity was presumably create
there's no reason to believe that's
entirely the case but that kind of seems
to be the case the issue with this is
that by the time you know with the the
the first wave rightly the first the
first generation of hounds that were
created they were designed for the
purpose to elicit sympathy from from
mutant kind the issue with this is that
they weren't really effective hunters
because they were designed to be more
more kind and more based in terms of
their function right so following this
came the second generation of hounds and
the second generation of hounds were
designed to basically insert themselves
into mutant encampments and then
basically like wiped them all out the
issue with this is as Jonathan Hickman
tells us because they were based on
being on the design of being duplicitous
right a design of basically betrayal
ultimately they betrayed humans and
machines and join the mutant population
right so it's very similar to the
concept of like Terminator the the idea
that they were basically taking like
human skin and sweat and hair and blood
all that kind of stuff and drafting it
over a robot skeleton and then sending
them into infiltrate that really kind of
Sue's me what's going on here with those
particular folks and so again what we do
is we pick up with Rasputin and this
young guy and tail and basically show up
with like what's left of the mutant
population and what you have here is you
have what looks like Groot wolf rain and
then you have I think it's Zorn or Zeon
I'm always confused on which one it is
and then you've got somebody who looks
like magneto now this is something I
want to draw your attention to
especially when it comes to magneto
there's no indication that is actually
him especially if we're dealing with
what's basically a hundred years into
the future magneto is powerful but he's
not really powerful enough to like you
know slow his own aging and so because
of the fact that the costume is
different the indication seems to be
that like it's a wholly different form
of his character like it's somebody else
who's taken over the role perhaps like
another like another son that he had
because we know Polaris has the ability
to manipulate magnetism but again this
is obviously not a woman and so it's
interesting here because what we end up
learning is that 100 years in the future
after this war broke out you can kind
took off to two different locations one
of the locations went out to what's
called the Shiar empire now the Shiar
empire is basically a massive empire
that exists out there as an amalgamation
of different races all swearing
allegiance ii to the Magister or
magistrate's but they've also had a lot
of dealings with the mutant population
specifically as well as earthlings and
so the notion here is that because of
the relationship between Charles Xavier
and lilandra who is that who was at one
point the magistrate's of the Queen or
whatever you want to call it of the
Shiar Empire their relationships have
always been maintained between mutants
the Empire itself and so the result was
that they basically offered safe haven
and so of the 10,000 surviving mutants
who were left on earth 8,000 live with
the Shiar the other 2,000 actually end
up living on the Shiar homeworld now the
8,000 are kind of like on an orbiting
satellite that kind of exists out there
but the other 2,000 are the most
powerful of them and they're basically
those individuals who can be picked and
chosen by the Shiar to join the Imperial
Guard the most powerful fighting force
in the entirety of the universe so again
there's there's kind of a lot that goes
on there for those mutants who exist now
who basically kind of reside within the
population of Earth there's only 8 of
them left that's really it there's only
8 mutants remaining on earth during the
events of the man-machine war and so
what we end up doing is picking up 1,000
years into the future now in this future
the scenario is pretty interesting in
terms of how it's played out and the
reason why is because of course again
you know Sanibel is still there but what
this also shows is that mutants
seemingly have won the man-machine war
mutants essentially took over everything
or at the very least humanity evolved in
the mutants and now everybody's a mutant
around the world but the other thing
that's kind of given to us here is that
humans are still around right like
humans still exist Homo sapiens are
still there but they're really kept more
like zoo animals the entire world in
order least this section is now called a
preserve right and they call it that
because like a nature preserve or an
animal preserve
humans are kept there they're monitored
they're there you know really sort of
left to run around in this small little
area and everything else has been taken
over nimrod has kind of evolved now he's
a small little floating machine more or
less and this person whoever this person
is we're not really given a name or
anything like that seems to be a mutant
of sorts or the very least evolved into
something else we're not entirely sure
but it looks as though mutants have
basically achieved ascension the mutants
have taken over everything and they've
achieved their highest level of
development more or less and so it's
kind of crazy because the war is now
over everything is done and mutants seem
to have won at all but again this is
only issue number one there's a lot of
questions that need to be answered here
there's a lot of questions that we got
to figure out and we don't know like we
don't know the answers to these
questions and in reality we won't find
out until all 12 issues are done right
until house of X the six issue house of
X series is done and the six issues
power of X series is done we won't know
until all those are finished what the
answers to these things are but I am
very very excited to find out with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop
alike and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you